which will be over in that corner
however we do ask that you purchase the
book at the bookstore register which
will be out near the front you'll see if
it's the place with all the books third
thing mr. Clark has also agreed to
answer questions and how that will work
is after the talk you know when the
moment arrives just kind of raise your
hand and I'll come around with the
microphone as you can see it's kind of
loud so don't like you know don't stick
it too close your face but do-si-do
speak clearly on both for the benefit of
everyone and for again c-span so today
I'm pleased to be introducing mr. Duncan
Clark and his new book Alibaba the house
that Jack Ma built co yeah I think I
think I'm not alone in that I first
heard about Alibaba in 2014 when it's
you know for the US IPO and it turned
out not to be are not only to be the
largest by any Chinese company but the
largest in US history period and you
know that's kind of amazing considering
that we don't really know what Alibaba
is it's hard to describe it's part a Bey
it's part Amazon part PayPal so on which
is why it you know someone with the
experience and knowledge of mr. Duncan
Clark is so valuable because he's a
founder and still chairman of DBA China
Limited which is a consulting company
based in China advising foreign
companies on Chinese tech and kind of
you know alibaba's statuses it's like
multitudinous you know explosively
successful company I think in a lot of
ways mirrors the Chinese economy which
is why you know someone with the kind of
insider knowledge that mr. Duncan Clark
does having 20 years of experience
there's he can explain it in a way that
very few can and I think we're very
privileged to have him here today so if
you can join us in our join me I guess
in welcoming mr. Duncan Clark
enjoy the talk
Thanks budget impressive committed all
that's a memory but you look like you
had a QR code in front of you I thought
you were reading that information from a
QR code that was great yes and I just
for those of you who have WeChat I just
did a look around on my WeChat so we can
all connect on WeChat which is
inappropriate because that's not an
olive our product Alibaba is a bit
behind frankly on the mobile stuff at 10
cents another company will talk about so
we can broad we don't have talked just
about long ago but we want to talk about
this thriving internet culture internet
society that is China today but
obviously there is this book called
Alibaba that you know my publisher
forced me to come and talk about no no I
want to talk about Alibaba it's my first
book but Oliver was Jack's third company
actually oh and I think whenever you
look at entrepreneurship entrepreneurs
failure is more interesting than success
and Jack had a lot of failure actually
you don't really get in to the book well
the book starts with a chapter on
Alibaba the company and then it starts
as a chapter on Jack them the man but
then we really go back in time to his
birth in 1964 and go through yeah a lot
of challenges I think hopefully one of
the stories one of the things that will
resonate most about this story I think
it is resonating is it's not just a
China story it's a story of overcoming
adversity and being underestimated and
cultivating being underestimated that's
what Jack is almost times to make we to
start with three things but firstly what
is Alibaba and I think taejun will just
say immediate it's kind of not an amazon
that kind of is in some ways it's kind
of not an ebay kind of business what we
mean by this is it you know has elements
of things that we associate with some of
these iconic companies in the US but
obviously the Chinese market is not the
US market so we wouldn't expect this
company to reflect exactly a u.s.
equivalent and Jack didn't start out to
create the Amazon of China and it isn't
the Amazon of China because actually
there was a company that did try to
become the
of China called eight eight four eight
which is the height in metres of Mount
Everest except that it isn't anyway but
it was convenient to have a lucky eight
eight four eight that it was an unlucky
name for company Jack did not want to do
a consumer ecommerce company in 1999
when he founded the company and he was
right because the Chinese market was not
mature enough for three important
reasons including people didn't have
enough money they also couldn't pay
easily for the goods and you couldn't
ship them reliably so we fast forward to
today one of the reasons that Ali Baba
is is so successful is that he solved
these problems um and he created what I
call that a sum an architecture of trust
now those of you who visit China over
lived there know that probably the
rarest commodity in China other than
fresh air is trust and I don't mean that
as a negative sense for the people of
time it's just the society has developed
in a different way society you know
trust was very much the preserve of the
family within the family and then
theoretically it was going to be the
state the party
but obviously those things broken down
and to ultimately create a successful
trading environment Jack understood he
had to arm close that loop and so he did
in innovations and people say oh there's
no innovation in China is really not
true
Ali pay yes it's partly like PayPal but
it's many other things actually a lot
better
WeChat we took another example of
another company I think it's better than
a lot of equivalents in the US and
elsewhere and what we you know I've
studied innovation at Stanford we talk
about what what is innovation people
often think of the Eureka moment of the
the light bulb and something radical
often innovation is like incremental
innovation it's market driven and that's
what jack has done he's not a typical
tech entrepreneur he is really an
entrepreneur or even an entrepreneurs
entrepreneur so you know in the book we
talk about what Jack calls the Iron
Triangle of how he solved these problems
so payment logistics and e-commerce it's
only those three things that he once he
got those things together did he become
very dominant in consumer e-commerce and
famously took
eBay and defeated them now I guess this
bookstore has sort of you know
left-of-centre origins I'm happy to say
that I almost became you know sort of
evil capitalist because I had a stock
options and I met Jack in that summer of
1999 and worked with him for several
years I was given the right to buy some
shares and I didn't in 2003 just before
they launched this consumer e-commerce
phone so that's the thirty million
dollar mistake so I think this gives me
street cred here but I had an
opportunity and I said no you know
because I'm clearly you know sort of
left-wing here but no but um you know
the fact is you know I underestimated
Jack and I'm not going to do that again
but it's because you know this problem
was so difficult
like nobody thought that anybody could
solve this problem and also eBay when
they you know started coming in people
said well Jax I mean nobody's going to
be able to to resist this huge US
company coming in evil large
multinational dinner I'm going to play
up to the left-wing thing here but um
they're basically you know was if you
remember some of you hopefully were born
back then or the dot-com crisis but uh
we had to boom we had to bust eBay
actually was a company that had kind of
survived reasonably well um and then
they said we're gonna happen to China
and it was the presumption that they
would just dominate and but Jack
outsmarted them and that's why Jack
today is really an icon it's the origins
of his iconic status in China is he took
on and defeated the big bad American or
international company that everybody
thought would crush this local upstart
and famously people talk about the his
quote the crocodile on the Yangtze you
know the eBay is coming across the
Pacific Ocean but once they get into the
Yangtze you know I'm waiting Jack is a
quote machine so I have here rather like
confetti at a wedding I can throw out we
win we went through an analyze every
speech Jack has ever given in English in
Chinese took a while I mean they're
great but he like a comedian there are
bits you know comedians have bits where
they basically the stand-up is not
really stand-up they actually have a
reservoir of these little little mini
tapes
things in their head and similarly I
mean we could just put pick one at
random I mean this is quite good those
is a good one
and this is random when everyone thinks
there is a great danger there are
opportunities hidden there they can be
brought out and I printed these as
though I'm working trying to make
fortune cookies actually because Jax
quotes are just made for these kind of
fortune so maybe there's a joint venture
if that's allowed ah with the store to
actually make these fortunes these mah
fortune cookies he's always had these
this folksy kind of charm
whenever the second point talk to rather
than the company will go back into more
detail about the company but you know
it's really about Jack I think this book
it was interesting as I started to dig
into his history I would I'd known him
again I've worked with him I've known
him since 99 but I didn't really know
him before that and I'd heard lots of
things I'd heard his stories but I
really wanted to go back and dig into
the real jack and essentially as I
actually found as a researcher
everything be doing research I invested
in fact IVA which is the Dow Jones news
search service because you think Google
has everything but it doesn't really um
ticker when you go back anyway I found
this news article from shortly after
Jack had started the company talking
about an Australian family that Jack had
met when he was fifteen years old and I
tracked down
this boy who was 12 years old when he
met Jack his name is David Morley and
he's been extremely helpful to me in
actually trying to really understand the
man and some of the pictures in the book
are never seen before
that was interesting because I don't
have you you talked about the IPO this
is when I decided to write the book
every story was just recycling the same
picture is the same kind of narrative
that was frankly bit tired and also
didn't often make sense it was just very
thin so I dug into this story actually
started calling David Morley's in
Australia randomly calling and emailing
and then I was getting at losing hope
but I emailed a yoga studio in New South
Wales and this guy emailed back g'day
that's me how can I help
and David based on that was probably a
you know I'm imposing a stereotype from
the UK on this guy
he probably didn't say good day and his
name was not Bruce it's David anyway
David's been great and he shared with me
the family photos and the whole stories
but it was a chance meeting of Jack with
this boy basically playing flicking
matches he was trying to basically burn
down a forest outside the hotel what
Jack was saying and Jack took interest
in this anyway it's a sign that you know
in life we always think like tickety's
wealthy people you know who created
these big companies was it luck
did they make their own luck and I think
you know jack has kind of made his own
luck because he is a person as I
mentioned he's really not a tech guy and
yeah we go back and see you know he
failed the math exams terribly I mean he
got 1 out of 120
I don't know how you even get that and
then he got like 10 or something I mean
he had to do it three times in China you
know it's not a society that really
values necessarily you know purely the
liberal arts or creativity you know we
all know the very language you know
involves huge amounts of rote learning
and and so this is a huge obstacle for
him but he'd already become a I think a
quite interesting person because his
English was was good was good I mean as
a team because he would go up to these
teenager people he would walk up to
anybody
frankly we get up at five o'clock in the
morning ride his bicycle this kind of
stuff we knew but I wanted to get some
of the detail and with the story of the
morally so true to the traditions of
this bookstore overplaying the left-wing
element which is good but it David Moore
Lee's father can this Australian guy was
a union organizer like his David Moore
Lee's mother was a member of the
Australian Communist Party until it was
disbanded and so Ken Morley had taken
his family to China in 1980 when Jack
was 15 because he wanted to show the
children three children a socialist
paradise they also went to Cuba later
that year 1980 and as a result of this
chance meeting actually Jack became a
pen pal with David and I have one
probably embarrassing for Jack a pen pal
letter but it's I think it's cute I mean
he's 15 and they basically correspond
and ultimately this Australian family
brought into Australia for a month yeah
this is a big deal in China in the early
ATS right and then they ultimately
helped Jack and the fiancee Cathy and
they bought him an apartment and then
that became the genesis of to how Jack
actually had some savings that could
allow him to take a risk and be an
entrepreneur okay so there's a lot in
the story I think there's a personal
element it's a corporate element and
then there's a broader picture of you
know what is what is the rise of Alibaba
tell us about China and its relationship
with the world and I think you know by
the way I don't know if you knew and I
think he might be here oh no he had to
go to San Francisco last minute but
Alibaba is opening an office here in
Washington DC I think they've already
opened it they've rented temporary space
opening a permanent office here they've
opened in New York they're already up
the west coast and one of the things I
did you know in the book I don't read
you but I've lived in China for 22 years
I find Chinese geography and
pronunciation of names even at today you
know it's quite difficult I go to the
airport when I speak Chinese but they're
cities on the the airport flight I've
never heard of you know until John
province is a large problem this is
where Oliveira is from this is where
Jack is from this is his constituency
but in the book so I have a map of
judging and showing people where it is
but I also have a map of the u.s. west
coast because we need to get to to know
the names in Chinese of US cities
because you know George in San Shi a saw
this is how the clustering of Chinese
investment which we've seen with Alibaba
up the west coast and it's important
because Jack actually discovered the
Internet in Seattle and I'll be there on
Tuesday of next week and there's a whole
backstory to how he got there
ready in a sense you know we've had this
West Coast tech and trade kind of
relationship that it's been underpinned
Olivar but now Alibaba is going to be
here on the East Coast and they're also
in Europe they're in London Paris Milan
Munich because they're increasingly
reaching out so the Third Point is
really Alibaba is having an impact on us
even if you're not in China and one by
its sheer scale is it's a huge company
as we heard its IPO was twenty five
billion dollars and all that but it just
surpassed Walmart to become the largest
retailer in the
and it doesn't have any inventory
actually it doesn't actually only those
goods it's a platform but this massive
scale is allowed because it doesn't have
to own the inventory doesn't have a cash
flow issue so so it's an impactful
business model but also increasing its
its going to be buying or bringing in
products that the u.s. makes and it's
not just coach you know bags or luxury
stuff that they're trying to move into
next week in Washington State I mean
I've met guys from the Washington State
Apple Commission and sherry producers
and cherries I mean last year at a
promotional event Alibaba
filled the equivalent of three 747s of
cherries in ice and within 72 hours they
were on the tables of you know cherry
eaters in China so this this kind of you
know I've doing a lot of radio
interviews without soaking somebody in
you know rural New York State and in
Pennsylvania and you know this is places
this is the dream that other wants to
have is that they can be the small
merchants kind of ally in the US or in
Europe as well as they are in China and
in China Jack's constituency is his
strength comes from representing the
interests of these small immediate sized
merchants I have a whole chapter on Jill
Jang province we know maybe some of us
know Hangzhou but we know when Jo and II
war probably eats chairs you're sitting
on probably most of things are wearing
probably most of the fixtures in this
room have come from II war in Incheon
but we can all they say awards are done
what it's a trading place I mean 95
percent of the world's toothbrushes are
made there for example so there's this
crazy element of concentration in this
province and I think what we're
beginning to understand is this has
helped propel this company alibaba but
we need to know we need to know like
what is the rise of the private sector
in China what does this mean this is
very different from the headlines of
China particularly here in Washington DC
we hear a lot and tomorrow I'll be at
the State Department and the
Eisenhower's talk about some of the
defense side of things but it is that
scary China frankly on territorial
ambitions nationalism but this is also
well there's a China sound not too far
from it's pretty small rather does that
kind of chime sound Lisa and actually
I've been involved in trying to connect
DC with China for some time we have
Sally Schwartz here we have Wendy could
we have some of the students who came
out to China to experience themselves
from DC Public Schools like this crazy
place that you know was so foreign but
has changed your lives I think right
this is my colleague Ted Dean who
actually introduced me to Jack maan
anyway there's a whole backstory
I love the DC Beijing connection because
there are actually some important
similarities between these cities we
have Allison Friedman here and some of
our team we're trying to connect the
hutongs of Beijing with the with the
back alleys of DC that you showed me
Sally just around the corner actually so
there's the people-to-people it sounds
trite but it's true people-to-people
matters and commerce is about
people-to-people ultimately and that's
you know the scary stuff will never go
away and it sells newspapers it scares
you know fear there's a lot of fear out
there I hadn't had a question yesterday
the Asia Society in New York like other
lessons from Jack's experience I could
Jack ever go into politics is it
possible for business people to go into
politics and I said well clearly the
u.s. as a shining example of why that
should not be the case so I actually
support the Communist Party of China
having a clear wall between politics and
business and long may they reign in that
aspect at least yeah because they I
think is actually interesting because in
a normal country or whatever it would be
I think to Jack as a very wealthy person
he has a huge constituency and you would
kind of think I think he's a politician
with a small pea I mean he he really
knows what he say he knows how to
motivate people I've seen him in 2005 I
I saw him on a stage with Bill Clinton
when Clinton was basically hired as one
knows you can do well that's up getting
political but Bill Clinton showed up at
Ali Baba event and to be honest I mean
the charisma you know Bill Clinton has
amazing charisma Jack you know has it in
spades too and actually in November in
in Manila
President Obama interviewed Jack onstage
plus a filipino entrepreneur but it was
kind of a reversal of protocol because
jack has if he was on the stage which as
they want that you never want to go on
stage off
Jack mom it's I don't even the videos in
sporting a mohawk or like singing and
you know and he's you know he's not a
tall guy he calls himself et you know
he's the extra-terrestrial also the
English teacher you know et but who knew
that somebody could go from being an
English teacher somebody who struggled
to become this big corporation so I
think we have to take some questions
because we can go in any direction and
I'm probably already doing that so at
least I can blame you this time you know
Terry first question I have a question
for you concerning team all yeah and so
when I'm here in the United States and I
going to want to buy some Nike goods I
simply go directly to Nike calm and buy
whatever it is I want to do but why is
it that Nike feels the need to go
through team all what is so special
about the team all website in China that
all these Western and international
businesses are having to go through team
ah what makes team also special I'm
really glad you're also question because
my friend Nick was doing exactly that
job with Nike yes so I can answer
specifically and it by the way brands
that are on Team L don't put everything
on their team ol store I mean brands are
special they think we're the best we're
you know we want to direct relationship
with a customer but often there's a
ecommerce do we have to you know but
actually the numbers maybe for some of
the higher end brands they want to get
like training wheels on cut and
consumers basically they want consumers
to know about the product so even if
Burberry's for example is on to go even
higher up team or arm you know they
don't want to start selling you know
their $5,000 coats on timo but they will
do this a scarf or that have some kind
of promotion it's interesting in china
you can also see like porsche keyrings
or you know ferrari eyeglasses right
it's like well getting when they're
young all right so it's like smoking or
something but um because ultimately
china if you think about china it's
standing on an escalator if you walk
onto the chinese market if you're able
to defend your position you're going to
be riding up why because urbanization
there you know there is still despite
the slowing the economy there is still
rising income there is a consumable
class so
so you're right so Nike for example will
be they don't have the limited edition
you know high-end stuff but they'll have
I think it frankly sometimes it'll be
like inventory clearing and things like
that but it's more than that in China it
is actually the most attractive way to
connect with the digital or the middle
class through this digital platform I
want to take digital it's really cell
phone now I mean it's m-commerce I mean
it's way over half I think 60 percent
now is is on the cell phone so it's
probably useful I think you're right to
say no so Taobao this this is another
site we have team all is more like a
like a virtual supermarket so in a sense
it's it brands that have their stores or
very large merchants Taobao is how
China's this is why stupidly I should
have invested but in 2003 they just
started this cycle Taba and that's when
small merchants and there are nine
million merchants selling on top half so
when I say nine million merchants I mean
that a lot of those are individuals so
it's my friend miss Wong you know and
miss Wong might be actually a government
official who doesn't have much to do
thank you know and she's trading during
the day you know um so maybe that's an
idea for bureaucrats in Washington uh
but basically there's a lot of
underemployed people in China as well as
unemployed people or people just need to
supplement their income and what these
people can do I mean I could start
selling you know plastic garbage cans
and I could and these are new this is
not an is why eBay didn't really work
initially exchanges like to buy new
stuff everything's made in China why
would you buy second-hand right so
people start selling things now they
could start selling fake ones I mean
this could be I don't know what the
brand of garbage plastic garbage cans is
but you know you said Nike we could buy
key
we could have psyche we can you know
there's a lot of fakes tikkun the early
days and Alibaba has been criticized as
part of that but the reality is they are
a platform and willing buyer willing
seller by the way a lot of people want
to buy fix not just in China most of the
Westerners we see in Beijing are hunting
for fakes right are they next is getting
hard because they've been shutting down
the silk market things like that but
interesting see the Chinese go overseas
to buy the real thing and I'm going to
repeat that I said this last night
probably got myself in trouble but I'll
do it again so I just was with
British foreign person what's-his-name
the chance of the exact so the telling
me to story about christine lagarde
so Christina goes walking down she's her
the I'm effort she lives here hopefully
she's not in the room actually she was
walking down the Sean's of these day as
one does in one lives in pet visits
Paris and a Chinese woman came up to her
and said can you come with me I'll give
you I think was 200 euros or 500 euros
excuse me what happens in China when
Chinese go overseas they want to buy
louis vuitton they want to buy Chanel
but there's quotas because these stores
know that there's basically parallel
imports you know somebody walks into the
store and one said I want hundred Louis
Vuitton bags as no no so that they are
allowed I think two of three so what
they do and it just happened to me as
well it probably happen to you you might
be able to pay for your trip to Paris
what I'm telling you this is great so
they go up to people on the street and
say come with me I just need your ID to
say you're buying furs and I will pay
you I'll pay upfront and then you'll
keep whatever it was and to her credit
christine lagarde said yes and so she
actually did she actually made where
there's 200 euros or 500 anyway so the
chinese want to buy the real stuff the
westerns want to buy the fake stuff but
chinese also on a biphasic look it's
it's a market Powerball is a scrappy
market and so how Alibaba keeps that
going what's important to understand
about Taba is that it's free so I could
sell these plastic garbage cans which I
might do actually this is quite exciting
this idea I could sell them for nothing
I mean babe I charge something but I
don't have to pay Alibaba
because it's free of course forget my
plastic garbage merchant store known I'm
going to probably spend some money on
advertising so Alibaba makes money on
advertising on Taobao but they make
nothing from listing fees and that's why
eBay died in China eBay famously said
free is not a business model well it is
they're wrong if you do something else
table are very Timor they do charge
Commission made it's two percent three
percent so Alibaba wants to do more and
more Teemo Teemo is actually becoming a
much bigger part of the business because
of course they make Commission and also
this issue of fakes but there's an issue
with team all so merchants sometimes buy
their own product it's called brushing
they
they may ship empty boxes or they may
just buy the lots of their product why
because it will get them up the rankings
and they're the number one licensed
plastic garbage whatever can company so
there is you know China those of you
who've lived and visited there know it's
completely unpredictable in a way that
we all become addicted to all right and
so in China if you want to cross the
road and I can see a stoplight here you
know Green does not mean it's okay check
out it's green is probably run with like
more awareness than red actually so you
know that's kind of how you have to
understand China it's just often
contradictory rules
I must find when show and expats when we
come I've sort of my first Belinda here
the other day work with the first day or
two when we come out of China you kind
of I find this I've yelled at people
trying to you know and they're like
chill you know it's because life is it's
it's not stressful but it's just it's
intense it's sort of you know but we
miss it we love it there but that's what
Alibaba has its captured that street
feel for example if you buy on Alibaba
from Taobao merchants so miss Chen for
example let's pick another example so
I'm tired of the plastic garbage can but
it might be I don't know well it doesn't
it's not for me but I heard recent sort
of a guy selling tights right within
stockings and all he does is a very
narrow range he's very very good but
many many people use this guy because
he's always been good quality it's
always delivered on time and he has
another job he works for Nestle actually
but he goes home and he makes five times
his salary just selling women's tights
on on on table off but what happens it's
not just a one-off kind of thing I mean
you they have a chat function called Ali
Wong Wong so it's like a it's like a
messenger client that pops up and you
have almost like the spoke vendors so
this mic is getting worse tights person
knows my god my garbage can vendor but
you basically have people who you know
are your guy which is kind of like the
Old Market right the fruit person or
whatever the umbrella person and they
will often give you discounts they'll
send you free stuff so Ali Baba's
thriving it's recreated that China that
we love frankly online
and eBay and others right now you have
to you have to fill in this form and you
know they just failed you know even
though they had a very good early start
eBay but they kind of messed it up and I
have a whole chapter on the humiliation
of eBay so her credit meg Whitman was
very early to see the promise of China
but I think she was let down by some of
the people in her team and I have been
people so the very long unrelated
question answer to your question where
any next question oh sorry I'll leave it
to you first of all thank you for for
being here and sharing the story of
Alibaba and Jack Ma I was wondering if
you could tell us a little bit about as
you said $0.10 and yes and badou as well
with respect to Alibaba as well as you
brought up in your discussion that
there's going to be a venture here in DC
as well as New York what is that right
get it so two questions so this is and
with the second question is there going
to be a government affairs office or
it's going to be just this again help
help me out with respect to what a
second weather is perd on and then I'll
forget the first one thank you for yeah
so the second one I mean I think yeah
those government relations I think Eric
ability is the representative who sends
his regrets he had to go to San
Francisco but you know they have a lot
of people who work in in the White House
in commerce in various in kind of
trading bodies you know so there look
clearly there's a political element or
at least government-to-government
element because we've seen how many
Chinese companies have not played that
card well I mean famously Huawei you
know which is a major manufacturer and
I'm Marissa from the UK my home
broadband in the UK is Squa way and it's
cheap and I love it but the u.s. no you
know I mean Sprint was not allowed to
buy from them and Maytag I think wasn't
Maytag puts a sophia's review because
the the Maytag man has not to be Chinese
or something I don't know so there's
yeah there's an awareness of the risk
there but there's also practical reasons
to reach out to the commerce department
I think penny penny Pritzker has visited
in fact my former colleague Ted Dean
through whom I met Jack Ma is now
working at the Commerce Department says
you know there's a grow
awareness you have to engage with the
government aspect and it's true also for
Alibaba in China's as endless question
you is how does I'll have a deal with
the Chinese come government and Internet
I tend to think of it not just in within
the country if it's on a global level
right I mean you have Apple in the FBI
you have so these tech companies have
huge power if you have a huge influence
of course they have to consult now I
have forgotten the first question which
was very early competitors so JD Tencent
well I just did to look around on on my
iPhone which is away.i well sometimes to
hook up but it's also a way to kind of
connect with your friends and around
price and so you know I can see all
right now here in DC there are looks
like hundreds of people including
probably Chinese students but also
others like ourselves you know who use
WeChat as an app for their daily life
and in China which we can't do here I
mean you can go out without your wallet
now I mean this is your digital wallet I
could send you money right now for a
great question for come on their arm you
know I could do a location everybody in
this room we could actually put
ourselves on a map say we were dispersed
over DC and we could converge on this
one point using WeChat so I mean there's
a huge functionality and that's actually
been a challenge for Alibaba they have
their own app called Lai Wang which they
were a bit late to the game and they've
spent a lot of money catching up they
bought wave war which is like China's
Twitter and they internationally have
invested in snapchat and things like
that so I've ever been trying to close
that gap but what's important for them
on e-commerce is that I think on I can
have up to I think it's 100 people in a
group or maybe it's 200 in my private
group but people are selling stuff this
way so the guy was saying earlier the
tights guy or the umbrella guy can have
a hundred people on that group and it's
very powerful because if my friend says
the you know these are the best
umbrellas then I'm more like to do it so
let's call wait yen so way Shin is
WeChat way again it's like WeChat
commerce right so a 10 cent is a company
based in Shenzhen which is a very
interesting town just across the border
from Hong Kong and it's worth actually
more I think
last I checked then Alibaba it's a
massive company so that's the main
competition on
Commerce I would say and it is mobile
arena by do you mentioned is China's
Google um partly because Google messed
up by leaving prematurely they didn't
need to frankly or anyway there's a
whole debate around that but also you
know they're not as innovative a company
frankly as they'd like to be or
certainly as Google is and Baidu is
struggled in e-commerce so they have
some aspects some headway in delivery so
right now in everything you do in China
increasingly just do from your cell
phone you can order any kind of food any
kind of product will be with you
normally within an hour sometimes within
ten minutes right so Baidu and others
have been investing in the service Oh -
Oh offline to online online to offline
so the merge merging effectively think
of Best Buy here and how difficult is
for them well China bought the
equivalent of Alibaba bought the
equivalent of Best Buy which is called
swinging or they invested in it because
you need to merge on the North line
commerce and you need to start blending
using cell phones and all this stuff so
yeah the main competition in China we
call it B 80 by do
Alibaba 10 cent it's really in my view
Alibaba 10 cent sometimes Alibaba and
ten cent gang up on Baidu they don't
really like Baidu
Robin Lee is not as a woman friendly
he's the founder of i2 as frankly Jack
Ma and Pony ma who's the head of $0.10
they're not related but um it gets a
look anything but for example uber so in
China
uber is not doing very well although
Travis Rollins often in DC so it was
carefully but you know it's one market
we're frankly they're they're behind you
know and the reason Alibaba and ten cent
both have proxy equivalents to uber and
they were very quick to scale because
they have this huge distribution and
they ended up it was so intense the
competition between this company DD & Co
ID that they ended up merging them
because at one point they were spending
hundreds of millions of dollars like a
month on subsidizing so you passengers
were being paid to get in a car the
drivers were being paid and in one case
Alibaba was offering free beer to
drivers so taxi drivers could come and
pick up a crate of beer not the most
intelligent of promotions but you know
it may have improved the driving given
the conditions on the roads in Beijing
anyway so they ended up merging and
interestingly now by do which partnered
with uber you see that Alibaba and 10
cent are investing in this main
competitor lifts ly ft who here uses
lifts and you like it yeah and thereby
do an uber is most people right but so I
mean I think you know this what
sintering this debate or what a
competitive landscape in the US is now
increasingly influenced by China and
vice versa so this is a 3d global
chessboard
if you can imagine that I don't know
what that looks like but that's what is
happening that's why the stakes are so
high in this competition yeah
yes up-to-date yeah take it up with
management oh it's a appreciate you
hello hi one child and we raise one
child one whole book with very pleased
happy thanks Duncan this is cross
marketing it were exactly we rates you
just sent me a thing on WeChat though
can I show you I'm going to ask the
totally pedestrian is very simple you
know total kind of I don't know [ __ ]
question which is this what is the
weirdest thing that you can buy on
Alibaba online I talking absolutely way
out weirdest strangest thing okay this
is c-span right buckle farts I avenge
her one guys on that another guy was
making earrings with made from mosquitos
and he they were quite popular so
mosquitos I guess in amber or something
in a kind of Jurassic Park fashion maybe
but then he got lots of requests but he
said it was quite funny guy Jack
actually told the story about this guy
people were saying well I'd like
matching mosquitos he said they're all
mosquitos or unique like snowflakes I'm
not going to do that for you right so so
okay and then you hate so one child
expert here so you can outsource a break
up with your girlfriend or partner on
top oh there are people who offer
services it's not just products
increasingly this is where we're moving
to its services so you you're too scared
to break up you get somebody else to do
it for you similarly you have a
the function you're under pressure to
you know show up with the date you know
and talk about the gay and lesbian world
you know there's all these horrible
stories of you know a gay guy marrying a
lesbian moon just appease the two
parents going horribly wrong but you
could actually just higher you know on
Taobao somebody is show up you know one
hour is X and you know and it's just
pretend to be you know so you name it
China increasingly the aging population
partly due to the one-child policy I'm
really overdoing it here for the
one-child there's a law I think that's
implemented you probably know this
though or at least was recommended that
they're refined
if people don't visit their aging
parents because you know Chinese
traditional habits were to visit your a
spare so you can actually hire somebody
to visit your parents I mean how great
would that be if you didn't have to fly
to Buffalo at Thanksgiving you know so I
don't know what the parents advance how
compos mentis your parents are I guess
particularly if a Chinese person shows
up if you're like me but that might be
but I think he visited yeah so I mean
anything you name it you know if it's
legal ish you can do it
so services yeah that that is opening a
whole new arena and that's happening
it's not just on our about them it's
just it's just a reflection of Chinese
society it's wild and crazy stuff is
happening there now the person who yes
hi for those of us who don't really
follow China that closely there are a
couple of impressions going around one
is that Xi Jinping has pretty much
continues to exert a lot of influence
including in the area of using
corruption to clean up the system if you
want to take one kind of headline right
on the other hand it's clear that
Alibaba is leading in a different area
that you used the phrase a global
situation you brought globalization into
that is there any interaction between
the ecosphere of the let's say Xi
Jinping world and the ecosphere of say
Jack Ma there is and could you elaborate
yes
no it's a very it's really a key you
know part of the conclusion is book like
where are we heading with this because
can we have these seemingly heading in
different directions worlds at the same
time you know particularly under she I
mean we wouldn't be having this
discussion so much under who Jintao
before but certainly under this
authoritarian centralizing you know
influence that is she
elements of nationalism I think he just
declared some holiday November 5th
September 15th is National Security
Awareness Day you know but two days
before Jack just declared the 9th of
September
joe-joe which interview fake Chinese Joe
is not it also means alcohol so with the
Italian Prime Minister Matteo Renzi I
think in Milano when it's deal whatever
it was Jack declared the September the
9th will be wine tasting day in China
and you know buy your wine now I didn't
quite Safeway still open but I mean the
Chinese going to clear it out ok so so
the one that we have is consumerist
China that's engaging China and we have
this scary like you know it's time for
national security day China so yeah in
the way I think of it is this so jack is
very dominant allograph is quite
dominant in e-commerce today it has to
move into new areas it has sometimes 70
or 80 percent of the market but the area
he's chosen to expand to to the biggest
are finance and media both of those are
sectors where the state plays a very big
role so I talked earlier about how Jack
created this Iron Triangle of you know
finance and logistics and e-commerce so
Ali pay again is the digital currency or
it's a currency put for digital things
in China it is increasingly for
everything and when Jack launched a fund
saying well you can if you have money in
your account you can just put it in a
fund we'll manage it for you we'll pay
you 2 percent more than the state banks
and they called it leftover treasure
right well a hundred billion dollars
went immediately into that into that
thing and the banks were scared even
though the bank's control hundreds of
trillions of yen they've never
experienced
like this and they've actually been
pushing back they've been trying to say
it's not safe you go to the bank each I
want to use a leave a wall are you sure
this Alibaba company that's an upstart
you know it's a two hundred billion
dollar company it's the banks are
fighting back and the same in media you
know i mean the fact Xi Jinping is being
complete increasing control state
control meet a lot of journalists
quitting things like that hopeless but
on the other hand you know the internet
is becoming a popular way of course to
consume information and Jack is looking
at ways to do that so yeah the way Jack
jokes about this one of the one of these
you know I forget how many 78 you know
quotes that he always makes it's
probably gonna be this one no this is
another one I think if people really
want to be successful they have to be
wise credible and audacious they must be
open-mindedness unrelated but he often
talks about the government if you never
marry the government fall in love with
the government that never married them
and may phone backs had a great the line
for this is like yeah it's Ali Baba and
the Forty wives because actually if you
do marry the government you're a
polygamist because there are so many
arms of the government they're the you
know and Jack actually confided to a
friend of mine last year as being
confided oops
when happen again 40,000 government
visits to Alibaba in Hangzhou in one
year and this could be you know the
parental head it could be the bureau
could be the local mayor could be
whatever but he can't say no I mean
course he can't meet everyone himself
and they have a whole thing I went on
the tour you know it's amazing you know
they obviously have lots of maps and
things people are proud Chinese are
proud of Alibaba including the governor
fischels so Alibaba is a bright and
shiny object the government can point to
to say China is moving towards a
consumer-driven economy you know we're
moving away from the old sign of
manufacturing
and so that's very useful the government
and out jack has made himself useful I
mean Jack's story is not a story it's a
strategy his whole life is about the art
of the deal of God comes later that word
is being very entrepreneurial and
knowing you know knowing what people
need knowing the customer and the
customer sometimes is the government so
I don't know the answer to where this
disconnect will happen certainly leak
lachung who nobody knows who's the prime
minister of China because given that
much power you know he's a good friend
of Jack and often I mean there Jack is
in an ounce of Jonah hi the center of
power talking about internet plus
economy this stuff but definitely matter
if she Jinping is really calling all the
shots and she's giving in Jack had met
but in Xi Jinping was party secretary
Sir John province so in theory there's
connections but we don't see this
chemistry nobody really has a chemistry
machine right now so interesting there
have one here from actually we actually
went we just met we had actually met in
Hangzhou in 2000 I think 99 even yeah we
haven't met since since then and you
were actually then and was at the US
Consul General in in Shanghai and I was
we went to meet Jack and his wife and I
think she tried to sell us real estate I
remember yeah she did
okay so do we have a mic brand here
sorry oh then we'll come back to you
sorry yeah we I think we need it for the
for the TV your answer sorry then we'll
configure sorry it's called when she
this is a connection Nexus in the many
years if I love China and I'm completely
out of touch but I read it jack has now
become involved and also some
philosophical pursuits and I'm wondering
if philanthropic yeah and I'm wondering
is that something that he's known for in
China as well does how does that
resonate with the Chinese and and is he
seen you know is any sort of a moral
authority as well for the way he's
conducted himself in his businesses over
these years and now is move it to more
philanthropic yeah it's a Jack Ma now
moves in very you know elevated circles
Warren Buffett and Bill Gates and you
name it Bill and Melinda Gates such an
early question about the world of
government I mean to some extent
jack is interfacing much more
effectively than the government of China
is with these people and you're right
there is an element of moral authority
emic jack has inspired by tales of
martial arts and history of China and
Chinese tradition dollars and all these
things so yeah you can argue itself
interesting because he's talking about
health care they're investing in
pharmaceutical companies but objectively
China has huge problems pollution aging
population and Jack wants to do
something about it so now in the u.s.
it's easier to do something about like
to be seen to be doing something for
example he bought a huge estate in the
Adirondacks to help preserve the trout
fisheries and the maple syrup you know
and you can do that it's actually
difficult to be a philanthropist in
China for example I personally I don't
think was him but with some billionaire
bought some land and then immediately of
course people come out of the woodwork
claiming this and that you know I mean
it's not easy it's China's still
debating how to deal with ngos in china
we call them gong goes government
organized non-government organizations
because anything that isn't the party is
potentially a threat you know so so yeah
Jack again it's another example where
Jack is pushing the envelope saying we
need to change these things and he is
taking lead post of people his friend
Jet Li you probably know Jet Li even Yao
Ming I work I'm at the board of wild
eight which is helping reduce the
consumption of illegal wildlife products
but Yao Ming has done amazing things in
actually saving sharks for example and
now rhino horn anything so individual
celebrity culture is in China too and so
the government needs to adapt be right I
think he is increasingly this is his
legacy mode now yeah and the development
of self-interest why not but I think I
think he genuinely cares about yeah
and the gentle if we can very patient
sorry yes and then we'll take behind
thank you very interesting commentary
the government of China has been trying
to move the economy away from the
investment and export model towards
consumption for many many years and
seems to be doing it more successfully
recently simply because exports of
thawne offered clip this mark model that
Jack Ma has come up with is very much a
mass-market model and do you see this
actually having a significant impact on
shifting the demand within China to a
more domestic oriented model or even
though the numbers are in the billions
and billions is is still just too small
apart to make that kind of a difference
and it's AIT's huge I mean you know to
talk about grocery deliveries we're
talking over 50% now online through
jacket is saying another one of these
things so I try not to put too many of
in the book please eat in the US
ecommerce is desserts but in China it's
the main course and what it means by
that is offline retail was never very
efficient in China so there two aspects
to your question I think is what can the
Chinese government do to encourage
consumption well actually what they can
do is create the conditions for people
to save less and spend more to save less
side of that is pension reform it's
labor market reform its investment in
social security because there's too much
mattress money precautionary study
that's not something that Jack and self
can do although they are looking at is
the thrust my question is is the
e-commerce space going to be significant
enough get to shift the economy right or
even despite the billions and billions
in
and money isn't going to be just a small
portion compared to the trillions and
trillions of the entire economy you know
I think the symbolism of it is as I said
the bright and shiny object is very
useful it does have a real impact in
reducing the friction of people to spend
money but it actually has not been easy
for people to buy things and
particularly also we talked about inland
cities where you know there were
state-run stores and so this is opening
up new markets so it's definitely
helpful whether or not this is the big
question now I can trying to make the
shift avoid the middle income trap it
depends where you go you know if you
were to go to Northeast sail on down
right now where my partners from and you
know you look at the terrible situation
with like coal mines closed it's awful
right but if you go to Hangzhou or Shan
Jen or Chengdu you can have a completely
different experience and whenever you
were living in Toronto for example you
were for a year so I mean there are many
different realities and I think our Baba
is trying to make itself into sociable
from that shift that needs to happen
that's good for them but it's also seem
to be good for the country and Joe ty
the vice chair who I interviewed
essentially in the book he said you know
it's like the the TN you know what's
good for what's good for America is good
for GM and vice versa
that's sort of what Ella was going for
we're so big we're so integral but you
know major slowdown the Chinese economy
would greatly problems but again we
still have this urbanization we still
have this aspirational culture it's
pretty hard to put that genie back in
the wall and I think that's what this
thing about giving consumers trust
giving the sense of choice that that's
really what is has been powering Chinese
economic revolution but yeah it's going
it's going to be a race against time
whoever hey back here really work back
Bay hi baby was like 15 years ago based
in China for for US News and World
Report so my question is actually
related to that so you know someone
who's sort of concerned about the
development of press freedom in in China
or lack thereof what do you think Jack
Maas intentions are with the South China
Morning Post right so Jack did
or actually Alibaba recently purchased
the South China Morning Post in Hong
Kong which you know is the main
english-language newspaper I think
there's one other still left but hanging
on
I actually met Jack Biggs our column
that my colleague Ted wrote in South so
many persons been some symmetry with
this whole story um yeah
Jeff Bezos as you know has purchased the
Washington Post and by all accounts
going well I think
I guess they moved and they have
creative people as a feeling of
editorial independence and dynamism I
don't lose any teenagers that's not
really an accurate comparison for Jack
because Jack personally he could have
bought the tower morose personally but
he did it through the company so then
you think well why the company doing it
because it is taking them into pretty
choppy waters I mean the Hong Kong has
probably never been more different
it's had some rough times in the past
right I mean think the culture
revolution tensions with the UK you know
but today Hong Kong is it's a divided
society you know and it's in fact we see
I think dr. Wong instead of us a new
political party after the Occupy stuff
so why would you wander into that there
is some argument well and it's not just
the South China Morning Post in that
group there's also like fashion
magazines and other states but it's
pretty hard to say that and they did
they're not unaware of the risk of doing
this so what were they asked to do it
that they want to do it did they have a
choice we don't know I mean the
companies defended it by saying in
frankly they're investing in the
business I would say they probably saves
the paper because it was on a slow
decline but but we don't know what
they're going to do with the editorial
stuff so they immediately got rid of the
payroll
but it's free is a business model thing
that they believe in they got they
scrapped that the paywall it's not
actually a very big business but it's a
very symbolic business because it's how
China and the West kind of interact or
seem to interact with this so I don't
know it's I think it's too early to say
I don't think they're going to use it
for you know Abbott Orioles for Alibaba
they're more mature than that but if
it's going to become a vehicle the
Panama papers were not in the South
America's that day and Nureyev attached
is a columnist we all love was showing
showing that they weren't frankly they
weren't in the New York Times I think
either I mean it took right it took a
while for these if they weren't
participating in the release with the
icao anyway who knows but there happens
a pretty hard-hitting story thanks still
in the post so you know they'd be dumb
to be completely saying today and they
drink nothing happened but in in Beijing
news is increasingly extremely sensitive
on domestic newspapers including some of
the more innovative ones in quanto and
elsewhere people being quitting right
and publicly saying why they're quitting
whether is sensitive because you know
might be high pollution count today so
it sports you know I guess just have
sports now that's that's gonna be a
thing or you know pandas of the zoo
right that's the whole show right so so
yeah I think you're right I think it's a
very low add journalists increasingly I
was just speaking with Orville Schell
last night who you know is written
extensively about what he sees is a
quite deteriorating environment I think
objectively we see that about how many
people are coming to him academics in
China who just want to leave and I mean
even remember a few years ago as well
move back to China and China has been
recruiting talent quickly in
biochemistry anything like that but in
certain aspects recently we see people
wanting to leave
you know so this is an issue for China
can it become an interpretive nation is
the talent is leaving or you know now I
think I don't in public schools here but
certainly in New York we're seeing more
more Chinese sending their kids overseas
because they were frustrated just like
Jax they don't want to do the gal call
and you have you know not have to be
genius in math that to study liberal
arts or something like that so there's a
lot of stuff happening in Chinese
society that it's it's like a boiling
pot where the governor right now is just
hammering down the lid probably not a
good idea but I think the Internet can
be a release I mean already social media
to some extent of allows people to vent
and also maybe you know bread and
circuses right I mean giving people
things that they can do play games you
know buy stuff resell therapy so I don't
know if the answer we'll see we have to
watch this afternoon because it's
Canarian in the coalmine friend
I think we exhausted yeah but there's
questions any comments yes we do sorry
I'm high in the interest of disclosure I
should say that we were in high school
together but we haven't seen each other
very much
yes it's me exciting to me yes right
yeah basically you're Ali Baba's our
marketplace hello you're saying that
they're essentially selling like crappy
plastic bins the origin the are
originally yes yeah and it's studying
more and more stuff and where the
Chinese are trying to build this
consumer based model and everything do
you see the emergence of like major
brands emerging in China and there's
already higher which makes and things
like highway whatever the problems they
may have do you think that the emergence
of global brands or at least very
powerful brands are they're very
powerful brands within China and do you
think that's a model that could be
expanding and that could play a part in
this expansion of the consumer base
society yeah I mean it is happening now
you mentioned some names fire you know
following the TGT
some of these or have more links to the
state others a more private sector I'm
wearing a Xiaomi band you know Tommy is
trying to be I mean lei Jun actually
wears black turtlenecks and has one more
thing slide although people say he's
joking but there is an element of his
desire to shift we look on the back of
your phone made in China design in
California you know Chinese enough
together along that they wanted
designing in China while we you know is
now a major the bleeding the smartphone
manufacturer firm average because it's
been investing heavily overseas and
ultimately this will mean a lot but more
Chinese companies will have to come out
because if they're just selling within
China there are already very established
Western brands in China and a lot of
Chinese brands have to go overseas to
buy talent by market and so the you
write the Internet may create a new base
for them to develop that's indicates
with Xiaomi which uses scarcity
marketing and uses like fan clubs and
things to take on the Nokia's in the
Apple
whatever even though they're kind of a
lower pricepoint so that's that's a very
good question like Chinese are
frustrated that you know name a Chinese
car all right
Volkswagen what's that Chile and what
are they buy you're right they bought
Volvo but they're keeping the Volvo name
I mean I think it's that idea this is
the smart thing hopefully I don't know
that the situation Chilean presence
right now but they know that it can't
really create a global brand themselves
yet Lenovo say it sounds vaguely Italian
right but it's actually the concoction
but they did actually buy the IBM
business so Chinese it's not like the
Japanese Wave in the 80s oh they just
like buy stuff and hope it works out I
mean they're more strategic but there
are some crazy things happening just two
weeks ago unbalanced right almost made
this major axon they already bought the
Waldorf Astoria Hotel for a price that
nobody can seem to justify so there's a
lot of money sloshing around China
there's also a sense among a lot of
Chinese entrepreneurs that they need to
keep talent keep brand so for soon which
is another judge young based company
called Club Med they bought the largest
insurance company in Portugal and then
the chairman actually went missing for a
couple days and we don't know why it's
still so there's it's interesting now
like if China like this is the fastening
air we heard about like how the
relationship between government and the
private sector and companies like
there's kind of a glass ceiling if China
gov to Gov relations with the rest of
the world for example Southeast Asia are
not great how does that help companies
Alibaba just spent a billion dollars
this week in Southeast Asia buying an
e-commerce platform there and yet the
Chinese government is having lots of
friction with those areas because of
maritime issues so it's all very
interesting so I have 12 chapters in the
book the chapter 13 is the most
interesting I just can write it because
because it's happening all the time
okay I think that's a cue to like wrap
this up so I'm happy to have you here
including friends I haven't seen from
City heaters and I'm happy to sign and
stay in touch you find me on WeChat we
normally chat you know Duncan Clarke
calm